Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 6 on programming with loops.
Before you get started make sure you've gone into Canvas and that you have
you have clicked week 2.
In week 2 you've gone and clicked the lecture exercise in programming with loops, the third tab over.
On the lecture exercise click the starter form.
When you get the starter form go ahead and rename it here so you'll be able to find it when we get started.
Now C++, like Java, has several different kinds of loops.
They have four of them. There's a while loop, there's a do while loop,
there is a for loop, and then there is the simplified for loop we saw in the last lecture.
But just knowing about these four kinds of loops really doesn't give you any guidance
when you want to decide what loop should I use for this problem.
For that you really need a different way of thinking about loops.
And so rather than thinking about the four kinds of loops syntax,
think about the five ways to control the number of repetitions.
Last lecture we looked at range iteration.
We visited every element in the container.
That's what the simplified or the range based for loop is for.
We have counter controlled iteration.
We're going to look at that today.
That's when we have a fixed number of times we're going to repeat.
Do this loop ten times.
We have a sentinel loop.
A sentinel loop is for input, when we look at the contents of input
and we look for a specific value that tells us to stop looping.
We have a data loop.
A data loop is also known as an end of file loop,
when we simply want to process all the data that remains in input.
So both the sentinel loop and the data loop are used for input loops.
Finally we have a limit loop.
A limit loop is when we want to do a calculation,
look at the calculation and somehow determine are we close enough.
Have we reached our limit?
And so we're going to use this to think about loops.
We're going to use these five ideas to think about loops when we write our loops.
So let's look first at a little bit of review for the range loops.
So C++11 introduced this new simplified range-based for loop,
similar to the for loop in Python
and the new for loop introduced in Java 5 in Java.
And so this will allow you to visit every element inside a collection.
It works on the string type, it works on the vector type,
it works on the built-in array type,
it actually works on all the collection types that are in the standard library.
And the basic syntax looks like this.
For, then you declare a variable.
Now you can specifically specify the type, like char C,
or you can use auto here, auto E.
Then a colon, and then just the name of the collection variable that you want to loop over.
This will go through each copy of the variable and put that variable inside E.
Now there are three variations in C++, Java has only one variation.
In, similar to Java, we can use value iteration,
meaning take the first element out of the collection,
put it in the variable E, put a copy of it in the variable E,
then take the second one, put it in the variable E,
then take the third one, put it in the variable E.
Instead of making a copy of each of those elements though,
we can actually look directly at the element.
And so this is for auto ref, again you don't need to use auto here,
you can use char or int or whatever the type of the elements in the collection are.
And this actually looks at the individual elements, so you can actually change them.
Now suppose our collection was filled with very, very large elements, say pictures.
You were going through the camera roll on your iPhone.
This first one would be very, very expensive to make a copy of each picture just to look at it.
The second one would be more efficient,
but it's possible that the function would modify the pictures in your picture roll.
What you might want to do there is use this third one.
For this third one, we look at the element,
but because of the const in front of it, we're prevented from modifying it.
Okay, so that was what we did last lecture.
Now let's look at counter-controlled loops.
So a counter-controlled loop creates a separate variable called a loop control variable,
and that will control the number of repetitions, the counter.
Now we can use this loop control variable two ways.
Traditionally we use this to the for loop, but you can do it with a while loop as well.
One way is when we want to loop through a string,
and we want to access the elements of the string,
or we want to access the elements of an array or a vector or something like that.
To do that, because the array and the string and the vector all start their element numbering at zero,
we want to start our index at zero.
And so because we don't want to think about how to end that, we use an asymmetric bounds.
Notice it includes the initial bounds, the lower bounds, index zero, but it excludes the upper bounds.
So notice it's less than ten here.
Now the name for these loop control variables, i and j, are very common names.
If you have a nested loop, you'd start with i and then go to j,
and then maybe k if you had three nested loops inside each other.
This int i = 0 is initialized before the loop is entered.
And the scope of the counter i, or the control variable i, is only inside the body of the for loop.
It doesn't extend after the for loop.
Now the test expression, the second part of this counter controlled loop, is tested before the loop is entered.
And so we call this kind of loop a guarded loop, meaning you can't get to the actions unless you pass the test.
This condition here is the loop guard.
Finally, after we've gone through and executed all the statements in the body of the loop,
we come back to this loop control variable and increment it here.
This is called the update expression.
This is not updated after we do the test, it's updated after we do all the things in the body.
Now the for loop can also be used for a second purpose.
That is, it can be used to generate a sequence of data.
And when we do that, you use a slightly different set of conditions, a different set of bounds called symmetric bounds.
What that means is you'll start at the lower bounds and include that, but you'll also include the upper bounds.
So if we wanted to write a loop that would print from 1 to 10, rather than writing for 0, int i = 0, i < 10,
and then printing i + 1, we'd print for int i = 1, i <= 10.
So when you generate sequences of data, you want to include both the lower bounds, int i = 1,
and the upper bounds, i <= 10.
Notice with the asymmetric bounds we didn't include the upper bounds 10.
We said keep going while i < 10.
Now for strings and counter-controlled loops, there is a pattern that you can memorize.
And first, initialize both the lower and upper bounds in the initialization section.
Both the upper and lower bounds, in other words, i and what you're going to test i against, the size or the length.
Use size t as the control variable, not int.
That's because strings, the size function, the size member function, returns a size t.
Initialize the upper bounds with str.size, and make sure that the control variable never, ever goes less than 0.
So some of the loops that you would write in Java simply won't work in C++.
Now we are going to use this first idiom we're going to look at. It's called the "building a string" idiom.
So the input for building a string will be a const string ref. It won't be modified.
The result will be an empty string. The output will be the empty string.
Each time you go through the loop, you'll concatenate something to the result to produce the output.
So we're going to do an exercise to show you this idiom and to get you started with some hands-on work with processing strings with counter-controlled loops.
And so this is the exercise called "to reverse."
And so this will be in A in your starter code in ICO6.
And so go ahead and put your name on the top of it.
So a "building a string" idiom produces a new string. So the output is going to be called "string."
"To reverse" is the name of a function. It takes a single string as an argument and produces a duplicate with the characters in reverse order.
You may use the library function "size" and "at." The argument will not be modified.
So "string to reverse." Its argument is not going to be modified, so it's a const string ref str.
The output is going to be a new string, so "string result."
And we're going to return the result.
Okay, so let's try that. Let's go ahead and, oh, I need to open a terminal on that.
So let me open a terminal on A. Open an integrated terminal.
So now we've opened that folder A.
And let's go ahead and do "make test."
And all of the code compiles correctly. Of course it doesn't produce the correct output.
It isn't reversed string, but we have the mechanics working.
So now we're going to go into that second pattern for counter-controlled loops.
So we're going to write "for something something do something."
So in this first section, we're going to create the control variable, the lower bounds, and the upper bounds, what the highest part is.
So we're going to say "for size p, i = 0, and len = str.size."
So notice we're doing both of these. Separate them with a comma, not with a semicolon.
Our upper bounds is going to be "i < len."
And then we're going to go "++i."
Now you might wonder why I can't say "str.size t, i = 0, i < str.size++i."
You'll see many people do that, but the size is not going to change here.
So we don't want to keep calling this function every time we come back to this condition.
So this is a better way to do that. Save the size. Make sure you save it in a size t.
So now we're at step four, or we're at the last part of the building a string idiom.
And what we're going to do is we're going to say "result = str."
And I can use a substring or I can use charAt.
So I can use strAt, or at, not charAt. strAt i + result.
So you notice each time, instead of putting the character after the one before it,
by switching the order of these two things, I'm putting the character in front of it,
and I'm reversing the string. I'm reversing the string.
I'm going to show you a couple more ways to do this, but let's look to make sure that this works correctly.
We'll do Ctrl+L to clear it, and do make test.
And in fact that reverses all of the input strings correctly.
Now many of you, I'm going to comment this one out, because that's a very simple way to do it.
Many of you would solve this problem like this.
You'd say for size p, i = strSize -1, i >= 0, - - i, result = result.
Or let's do the shorthand, result += strAt i.
Now this would make sense in Java, but it has a problem here.
Here, when i is 0, it'll add the first element here, at the end of it.
Then we do i - -. Well that doesn't go to -1.
As a matter of fact, this condition cannot ever be false.
And so if we come down here, and we try and just make it, notice we get an error there.
We're doing a comparison of an unsigned expression, greater or equal to 0, by definition is always true.
By definition is always true.
And so that's an error. This piece of code is an error.
Also, even if it did work, what if the input string was empty?
Again, strSize -1 would not be, strSize would be 0.
0 - 1 is not -1. It's all unsigned numbers.
So when I subtract 1 from 0, I get the very, very large number 18 quintillion, or something like that.
Very, very large number.
So this simply won't even compile.
We could fix it like this.
So now it'll compile, but down here, we would need to remember to go i - 1.
Because of course, strSize would crash when we ran it.
When i was strSize, and we tried to get the str at strSize, that is out of bounds, and it would crash at that point.
So this version will work as well.
Let's go ahead and clear that.
And do make test.
But you can see if you want to do that, you have to always be aware that you cannot go less than 0.
It literally is impossible for you to do that.
So either two of those are perfectly fine.
Okay, so now let's look at processing substrings.
Here is a substring catapult.
Notice that it has 7 characters, or 8 characters, indexes 0 through 7.
Suppose we want to count the number of times the cat appears in the string.
Well, I would need to look at 3 characters at a time, not a single character like the idiom we looked at before.
So this algorithm and technique is worth mentioning.
Worth memorizing.
So here we have 3 variables.
We have our counter control variable i,
slen, which is going to be the length of our substring, cat in this case,
and len, which is going to be the size of the string, in this case 7.
We set i and slen, i, not to be 0, but to be the size of the substring.
So i is pointing right here at 3.
Then in our loop, rather than stopping at i less than len,
so len of course is 8 in this case because there are 8 characters,
we're going to go i plus len, so we have a little pointer here, or an index here,
where we're going to stop, this second little arrow right here.
Now we're going to extract the substring we're looking at
by taking s.substring, i minus slen, slen.
So again, this is something you can memorize.
It will always work.
And then you can do conditionals to examine the substring that you extracted.
So we're going to do this with an exercise called count.
And we're going to count the number, just like I'd count the number of cats here,
we're going to count the number of times the code appears in a string.
Now there's a couple little details here that make it a little bit more complex.
So this is going to be b.
I'm going to put my name on top of it.
And I'm going to go ahead and open a terminal here
on b so I can write code on it.
So let's look at the instructions.
We're going to write a function called count code.
It will take a single string as an argument.
It will not be modified.
It will return the number of times that a pattern like code appears in the string.
Any character at all is acceptable in place of the d.
You can use size, substring, at, and back.
You may not use find.
So this is going to return a count, so it's not going to return a string.
It's going to return an int.
The function is named count code.
The argument is a string that's not modified, so that's a const string reference str.
The result in this case is an int rather than a string.
And if you do that, you're going to have an error, because result is a primitive type.
It's uninitialized, so we want to initialize that to zero.
And finally we want to return the result.
We'll go ahead and check to make sure that I have the syntax right
by making it and testing it.
So I'll make test.
And I actually got 40%.
I didn't really do any work on it, because I'm returning zero,
and zero is correct for several of these answers.
Code doesn't appear.
But the important part here is that it compiles and it links,
and I have that part correct.
Okay, now our variables.
So size T, SLEN equals four.
We're looking for four.
And our loop for size TI equals SLEN.
And, of course, LEN.
LEN equals std size.
I less than or equal to SLEN.
To LEN, not SLEN.
Plus plus I.
So that will allow us to go through and get four characters at a time,
which we'll do with substring.
So string subs equals str substring I minus SLEN.
SLEN.
So we're getting four characters at a time.
Now we can see, now I know I'm guaranteed,
because I've memorized this idiom right here,
I'm guaranteed that I have four characters in subs,
because I've made sure that this only allows me to get four characters at a time.
And that means I can say if subs substring zero two is equal to CO,
it starts with CO, and subs back equals E,
then it's that code pattern I'm looking for.
And I can increment result.
So here's the pattern for processing substrings inside a string.
So let's try that out again.
Let's clear the thing and do a make test.
Now let me show you another way to do it, just like I did previously.
So this is the way I recommend, but,
actually I'm going to leave SLEN there.
I'm going to comment that out.
We could do it like this.
I'm not quite sure what just happened there.
I must have, oh, no.
Let me save it.
I'm not quite sure why I'm getting a,
I have no idea what this is.
Hold on, I'm going to pause this for a while while I try and figure out what,
okay, I'm back.
I don't know why it was doing that.
I just kind of ended up closing the little window that opened up and did it again.
So let's try it this way.
Let's try it forward.
So for size p, i equals zero.
LEN equals third size.
I less than LEN plus plus I.
String subs equals third subster,
I SLEN.
So starting at zero, getting four characters.
And if subs size equals four,
and subs substring zero two equals CO,
and subs back equals E,
then result plus plus.
So this will work as well, but notice I had to add this extra case here,
because it's possible that I wouldn't get four characters here
when the I is gone past the length.
Now, you might try and fix that.
In fact, in Java you would fix it by simply saying size minus three.
Why doesn't that work here?
That doesn't work here because these are unsigned numbers.
If the length is less than three,
this will give you a huge number and your program will crash.
Program will crash.
So I'm going to leave that there.
I'm going to comment out this part right here.
And I want to show you the program crashing.
Because you'll notice on our inputs here,
we have two strings, one string that is less than zero.
And so this is the effect we'll get if we do that,
which would be the standard way you'd write it in Java.
Make test.
And notice this substring pos, which is one, this size, which is zero.
So notice that this aborted, it core dumped,
which means basically that it crashed at that point.
So this thing that would work in Java simply won't work in C++.
So we can put it like this.
And let's make sure it will work again.
Let's do make test.
Okay, so that works perfectly fine.
But I actually think this is a little more complex.
It goes through more times than are necessary.
And I think learning this one is a little bit better.
This one is a little bit easier.
So I'm going to comment out that one.
Even though it works, I kind of don't like because it's a little complex.
I'm going to uncomment this one.
And you comment and uncomment with just control and the slash character.
Control and the slash character.
And let me just go a third time to make sure it works.
Control L, control L.
And yes, we get the right answer.
Okay, so processing characters right here.
And look at the two reverse example we did.
And processing substrings, this one right here.
Now there are a couple of other loops.
Those are the only two exercises we're going to do.
But I want to talk about a couple of other kinds of loops,
which are indefinite loop.
The simplest indefinite loop syntactically uses while.
And basically it's while the condition is true,
do these statements over and over and over again.
So let me show you a while loop and tell me how many times it repeats.
So I call a function randchar.
It gives me back a random character and I store it in the variable C.
Now while C is not equal to the Q character, I print out C.
And then I set C again to the next random character.
How many times will that loop repeat?
Well, it might repeat once.
It might repeat not at all.
The first character I get might be a Q.
Or it might never come up.
The randchar function might in fact never return me a random Q in that case.
So you can't tell by looking at the loop.
And that's why we call it an indefinite loop, an indefinite loop.
Now one kind of indefinite loop is a primed sentinel loop.
A sentinel loop reads from input.
And when it reads a special value from input, the sentinel, it stops.
The primed loop is one technique for writing a sentinel loop.
It was named after this old-fashioned water pump.
And the old-fashioned water pump back in the old west
was simply a pipe stuck in the ground with a piston inside
that drew water from down underground by using suction.
But to get suction, they had to have a good seal around the piston.
And so to get a good seal, you would first pour a bucket of water into the pump.
That would create a seal around the piston, and so you could start pumping.
And that pouring the bucket of water in before you started pumping
is called priming the loop.
And so this loop is called a primed loop.
And here's the algorithm for that.
You read a value into a variable.
If the variable is not the sentinel, you process the variable,
then read the next value.
So while the variable is not the sentinel, process the variable,
read the next value.
Now, we could do the same thing and not require two read statements.
So look back here.
Notice I have read a value into a variable before the loop,
and at the end of the loop I have read the next value into the variable.
What if we only want to have the read a value into a variable part once?
For that, we can use a flag-controlled loop.
So instead of two read statements, you can use a Boolean flag
to signal if you've found the sentinel.
So here you'd create a flag.
I've called it finished here of type bool, and I've set it to false.
I'm not finished.
Then my loop control is while I'm not finished.
Now I read the value into the variable.
Notice I'm only reading once.
If the value is the sentinel, set finish to true.
Otherwise, or else, process the variable.
So this is the code for a flag-controlled sentinel loop.
Finally, we can use what's called a loop-and-a-half idiom.
Now, normally a loop has only one exit at the loop condition,
at the while or the for.
Some languages, however, allow you to exit from inside a loop.
Ada, the language Ada, does this with its exit-when construct.
Now in C++, you can do the same thing Ada does
by using an if and a break.
And so this is a loop-and-a-half.
While there is more data to process,
read the value.
If the value is the sentinel, then exit or break.
Process the variable.
This is called the loop-and-a-half idiom, as I just mentioned.
Now, many programmers don't like this.
I actually am relatively fond of it.
I think it's easy to understand.
And there is a paper that you might want to look at.
On the slides you can find the link to it.
It's "Loop Exits in Structured Programming."
Now, it's an old paper. It's from 1999.
It's talking about the Pascal language, so it's not exactly up to date.
But it, in fact, provides good reasons
why this is actually a pretty good loop-control strategy.
Why it's actually better than some of the other ones.
Well, that's it for this lecture.
We're going to follow up on these loop-and-a-half idioms
and learn about exits in our next lecture
when we're going to do more on loops.
[no audio]